the Joe Rogan experience well that kind
of recovery stuff is so important guys
that think they could just work out and
and not take that time and recover right
I was that guy though I was I mean you
you learn more I mean I when when I
needed when this ripped we this was the
full tab finally like my my tendon
exploded it didn't rip actually it
exploded so they were still is that when
you were doing the hercules thing no no
that that was after that was after so
that when that happened it wasn't it
didn't fully separate so but when when I
went home and I was training down the
road this was like a little while later
so you didn't even get surgery
immediately
you couldn't you can't why because first
off if it's muscle or if it's not
completely separated you came to surgery
but this basically what I'm saying is
exactly what's his name just a different
time period I this exploded off the
tendon when I was doing a world-record
attempt for an axel in training and that
I I was like I knew it was tore right
away but we had the pilot for the TV
show we were supposed to film in Nova
Scotia Canada this next day and I knew
what an opportunity it was so I said
[ __ ] it and went took a shower and got
on a plane and I flew to Canada and in
Canada with with it completely torn
knowing that I needed surgery and
hurting like like the worst pain ever
we had to flip a boat select one of
those little row boats we had to flip it
like a tire then we carried three
hundred pound water jugs up a hill we
did like all this stuff with that
separated and the entire time it just
felt like someone was stabbing me with a
cattle prod but that one that was meat
head but we worried that you were doing
more permanent damage though not on the
bicep no once once the bicep goes the
only thing worse you can really do is
shove it up higher so they have to Flay
you deeper when they pull it down and
lays it hard in Inquisition type torture
device right but I had a I had a great
surgeon I was I was taking care of man
and it was it wasn't too bad how long is
the rehab
to mellow no no three weeks in a cast
and then like he gave me this like an
arm brace that would like I'd adjusted
every week or so to we're good more and
more straight and then that was maybe
three months before I could use it and
at that point it's not like I could go
do what I was doing it's at that point
you start over Wow yeah and it was my
arm was like tiny I was but I was pretty
pissed off leaving your arm Chinese
probably but how weird is that I'm
walking around like one on like this and
the other one looks like it works a bit
like some IT company well you know bas
Rutten you know yeah yeah I met him a
few times box has what he calls baby arm
is one arm that's small because of
atrophy because of pinched nerves right
this is really it's really kind of
[ __ ] up yeah it's like to this day he
I don't think he can hold up a jug of
milk oh sure like he couldn't like hold
a jug of milk in his arm extend his arm
yeah that's a guy that for some reason
didn't get a lot of the love that he so
deserves he was a pioneer Savage yeah
and one of the most like one of the
original technical strikers right taking
on dudes way bigger than him and still
handle them like hoist Gracie is amazing
and savage but he was doing the exact
same thing oh yeah yeah he was just
years later but if hoist had to fight
bas Rutten it would have been ugly but
no the thing is like in the early days
boss didn't understand submissions
either so hoist would have probably got
him if it was like UFC one right you
know it's um it's a crazy sport and the
people that have been able to you know
like pave the way like a guy like bas
Rutten yeah they were such a so much
he's such a savage he would just shoot
cortisone and everything all of his
joints are all [ __ ] up yeah you just
take cortisone shots to shoot it into
everything well lidocaine shoot
lidocaine into his shins oh my god so he
can [ __ ] blast people not feeling it
man we had amazing stories though we
went to his gym we did I did mas mas
wrestling is like an old Russian style
wrestling why you
like a stick and you each hold the ends
of the stick and try and take it from
each other ah and we actually I did it
twice
and two tournaments and I was the
undefeated American champion for a year
and a half but after doing it twice but
we went to his gym to do the qualifiers
to go to the World Championship in Dubai
and he came out there and he was judging
and stuff and I remember like I
basically I was way bigger than most
people and I'm like upper body heavy so
I just lean back and take hit and at the
end of it he walked over and he goes
he's like the force is strong with you
son I love this guy yeah he's got a
great personality he's he's a great
commentator - it's great at that it's
fun
yes he makes [ __ ] fun now he seems like
cool dude
[Applause]